So you might ask, how did I get this list of
files that I used to my manifest? I could just list
every file coming from a directory listing from my server. But
I don't want to grab things like Python files. So, the easiest
thing to do is to get files that you know you're
going to need, like the images I knew were referenced. And
the JavaScript files. And then walk through one at a time
and see what happens when you try to run the app
from the cache. Let's try this now. Let's take
a couple of these files out and see what happens.
Let's save the manifest file, and go back and
reload. Now remember, even though we downloaded a new cache
here, what we're looking at over here is not
that uploaded content. We need to refresh one more time.
And now you'll notice that when I try to
get this file from my application, it just fails. Now,
if I had put in my manifest file under the
network section, star, that would mean anything could come from
the network. I find it's a useful trick to not
use network Star because then you can see what's failing.